-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope we're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
The Supreme Court ruled today
that the EPA does not have
the authority
to set emission standards
for existing power plants.
But they are gonna let you
use the smoke
for gender reveals.
[ Laughter ]
Today was the final day of the
Supreme Court's current term,
and I got to say, thank God.
This must be how the Jets feel
when halftime finally arrives.
"Hey, well, we get 15 minutes
where they can't
kick our asses."
Wyoming Representative
Liz Cheney spoke yesterday
at the Ronald Reagan
Presidential Library and Museum
to discuss the future
of the Republican Party.
Well, I hate to break it to you,
but the future
of the Republican Party
isn't at a library.
If anything,
you should have held it
in the comments section
of 4chan.
[ Laughter ]
Ketanji Brown Jackson
was sworn in today
as the Supreme Court's
116th justice,
and then Clarence Thomas
dissented against that, too.
[ Laughter ]
Following
the Supreme Court's decision
to overturn Roe vs. Wade,
urologists have reportedly
seen an uptick
in requests for vasectomies --
and this is weird --
from women.
[ Laughter ]
"His name is Dave.
I'll bring him in."
[ Laughter ]
Senator Bernie Sanders
sent a letter
to Transportation Secretary
Pete Buttigieg this week,
calling on the department
to take immediate action
on issues with air travel,
specifically those fun
safety videos.
[ As Sanders ] Just tell us
where the exits are
and shut up.
We don't need a funny video.
No rapping.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Animal Control officers
in Nebraska recently removed
a Miller Lite can that was stuck
on the head of a skunk.
God, that smell was awful,
said the skunk.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Idaho
recently broke
a Guinness World Record
by walking nearly 3 1/2 miles
with a guitar
balanced on his chin.
The bad news -- he's walking
to your party.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!